el secreto de exxon Mobile al
descubierto de acuerdo a un nuevo
estudio la petrolera predijo con
exactitud del calentamiento global a
pesar de poner en duda la crisis
climática durante años
Naomi es una de las académicas que
analizó los datos de los documentos
internos de la empresa
en 1988 reconocieron que se trataba de
un problema muy grave
Así que claramente Aquí está en blanco y
negro saben cuál es el problema y saben
lo que están causando sus productos
la investigación Privada de Epson decía
el efecto invernadero puede ser uno de
los problemas más importantes de la
década de 1990 otro elemento clave de la
investigación este gráfico de los años
70 que predecía con exactitud una curva
ascendente de las temperaturas globales
y las emisiones de dióxido de carbono en
los últimos años estados ciudades y
condados de Estados Unidos han
presentado decenas de demandas
judiciales acusando a Epson de engaño
público y exigiendo miles de millones de
dólares por daños climáticos esta nueva
investigación podría aportar más pruebas
a esos casos a medida que avanzan en los
tribunales sin embargo
negando cualquier delito esta cuestión
ha surgido varias veces en los últimos
años y en cada caso nuestra respuesta es
la misma quienes hablan de que éxon lo
sabía se equivocan en sus conclusiones
en los últimos años otras empresas de
combustibles fósiles también han sido
objetos de críticas por restar
importancia a la amenaza del cambio
climático